your assessment of the situation right
now and how tense it is getting more
dangerous by the day so here's what to
watch for
if the iranians follow through on their
threat to
start enriching again at higher levels
to basically
take their enrichment program to a kind
of a nuclear level in terms of
weapons grade production israel's in the
world to hurt
so the best thing the president can do
is stop that and how do you stop that to
make iran
understand you're not going to let that
happen i think he should put their oral
refineries on our target list that he
should look at sinking the iranian navy
if they attack shipping again
but what i worry the most about is a
conflict between
israel and iran and we're going to come
to israel's eight if that happens
well you know asked about the oil tanker
attacks on tuesday time magazine quotes
the president as saying this
so far it's been very minor
what you're saying is that it's not mine
well what i would tell the president is
you're right to withdraw from the
iranian nuclear deal you're right to put
sanctions on this
uh state sponsor of terrorism they're
the most murderous regime on the planet
and that's saying a lot
mr president the attacks on the oil
tankers in the pipelines
has to be dealt with but the big problem
is if they go back to enriching at a
in a manner that could lead to a bomb
you're putting israel in the world to
hurt and the entire world should
should be worried about this but if
you're a european ally looking at this
are you sticking with the us are you
trying to find an escape valve
economically for iran see why why is
iran doing this or trying to divide the
europeans and the americans
nobody wants a conflict with iran but
nobody should want iran to get a nuclear
weapon nobody should want to run to sink
ships and blow up pipelines
norway and japan never said a word about
their ships being blown up by the
iranians
so this aversion to a conflict with iran
is going to lead to a major war
if somebody doesn't bring them back in
and that's somebody's united states
so if i were the president i'll tell the
iranians if there's an attack on a ship
or a pipeline or anything like that
we're going to blow up your oil refinery
and take you out of the oil business
because they're trying to drive up costs
for creating chaos
but the main thing is to tell the
iranians if you go back into enriching
the way you were before
that's a direct direct provocation
against the united states and israel and
we will stop that
israel cannot allow the ayatollah to
develop a nuclear bomb nor should the
united states
all right so the secretary of state says
they're going to deter aggression
the president does not want war where is
your red line
are you saying if there's another attack
on an oil tanker or a u.s
person is killed what is what's that my
red line is if there's any more
disruption of shipping in the straits of
hormones linked to iran
take out their navy bomb their
refineries if there's any more attack on
american
interest go after the iranians so
they'll pay pain
they'll they'll feel pain i'm not
talking about invading iran i'm not
talking about a land invasion
if they go back into the enrichment
business at a level that would lead to a
nuclear weapon we need to sit down with
israel and
other allies and come up with a way to
stop
you talk to this president a lot now
yeah you didn't used to but you do now
so is this president ready to do that
he's had it with iran
so yes he is i think the president is
going to stop them from going
to get a nuclear weapon i think it's
going to stop them from disrupting the
flow of oil
and blowing up the pipelines of other
nations he doesn't want a conflict but
he's about to run out of options here
remember this if you remember nothing
else about this interview
israel is not going to allow the
ayatollah to enrich uranium in a fashion
that will lead to a nuclear weapon to
destroy the state of israel
nor should they that's what's about to
happen in the next 10 days we're headed
to a conflict here
between the ayatollah who is a murderer
stug
israel and maybe the united states and
the rest of the world within 10 days
if they do what they say they're going
to do i know bb very well
he is not going to sit on the sidelines
and let the second
holocaust be set it's not going to
happen
all right there's a u.n report out about
the saudis and the crown prince it says
quote every expert consulted finds it
inconceivable that an operation of this
scale could be implemented
without the crown prince being aware at
a minimum talking about the
killing of jamal khashoggi
is the administration ready to take this
evidence
or will the administration back mbs
regardless you know on this in this area
i think they've
they've got it wrong mbs did it this man
was killed at the direction of mbs
couldn't happen without him knowing
about it and he's doing
things like that all over the place he's
bringing people back into saudi arabia
god knows what happens to him
put the lebanese prime minister in
prison for a while
the bottom line is i've been briefed by
the intelligence community
there's zero doubt in my mind this was
orchestrated by
mbs himself that's not the way to treat
a strategic partner like the united
states and i'm not going to accept
business as usual
saudi arabia but the administration
doesn't seem to care about
what you want it does and i can tell you
this when you look
weak in the face of things like this it
hurts you everywhere
this is absolute disrespect to the
president of the united states
and myself i introduced mbs three years
ago two years ago in town
hailing him as the new vision and the
new voice of the mideast
embracing his agenda of reforming saudi
arabia
only to be played like a fiddle so if
you really want to make america
respected again throughout the world
deal with abuses by allies not just
enemies
so when you hear secretary of state
pompeo say our strategic
alliance is more important in the big
picture what do you say
they would be speaking farsi in saudi
arabia if it wasn't for us
they're not protecting america from iran
there's no amount of oil they can
produce
there's no threat from iran that will
allow me to justify this behavior
a strategic ally has to act in
accordance
with the relationship meaning something
how do you murder
somebody chop them up in a consulate in
a foreign country
and expect the united states to give you
a pass because you produce oil that
would be a huge mistake
you're on the senate armed services
committee did you know patrick
shanahan's past and this stuff about
domestic violence
i've heard of that i don't know the
details does the administration have a
vetting issue
after this or before this you need to
ask them all i can say is that we need
a new secretary of defense the secretary
of army and
esprit is a great guy he'd be a good
secretary of defense but
we're having a conflict with iran we're
going into budget negotiations with the
congress
we need leadership at the department of
defense i like president trump's foreign
policy
but we need a secretary of defense that
has his confidence that can get
confirmed
in a permanent fashion obviously he was
deputy secretary it was approved
in your committee yes i think there's a
pathway forward let's just use it
a couple more things you heard the story
about joe biden getting heat from
democrats about
talking about his time in the senate
your thoughts about that if you want me
to give you a list
of why i can't deal with you because i
disagree with you
i can make a long list for everybody
running for president on the democratic
side
if that becomes the norm that we can't
work with somebody because
of whatever position they take we don't
like
then it's over joe biden did nothing
wrong
by working with a duly elected senator
from a state
from a past that we now try to move on
from
what he was trying to say is i work with
people that i didn't agree with for the
good of the country he spoke at strom
thurman's funeral
now does that mean that he agreed with
strom thurman the dixie track candidate
no that means that over a 30-year period
they got to know each other had definite
differences
but they found a way to do business so
if you can't do business with the other
side
where does this country go into my
democratic friends
i can find a lot of things you said i
don't like
right well last thing you got a standing
ovation last night at this
at this rally and uh you were there
you're obviously supporting the
president for re-election
is he most concerned about joe biden as
you talked to him
he said something that makes a lot of
sense no matter who they nominate
they're going to move the country toward
a socialist agenda look at what joe's
going through
by talking about being bipartisan i
don't know if joe can make it through
this primary without becoming a
socialist
embracing impeachment here's the
president's ace in the hole
he's done a damn good job and what the
other people are offering will take the
country backward not forward
stay on message mr president you've got
a good story to tell
tell it but to have 25 000 people show
up for an hour and a half
there's some magic there and if the rest
of us in this business don't appreciate
that magic
we're making a mistake